compte tenu de l'évolution de la crise
sanitaire les restaurants bars et cafés
pourront ouvrir dans tous les
départements à partir du 2 juin mais ils
ouvriront avec des restrictions
temporaires dans ceux qui se trouvent
dans les zones oranges
là où une vigilance particulière est
nécessaire partout cette ouverture sera
conditionné au respect des règles
sanitaires qui ont été validés avec la
profession d'ailleurs les personnes qui
ont choisi de dîner ou de déjeuner
ensemble pourront s'asseoir à la même
table dans la limite d'une capacité
maximale de 10 par table mais il devrait
y avoir une distance minimale d'un mètre
entre les tables de sacs groupe
les circulations à la terre des
établissements devront être organisées
et le port du masque sera rendue
obligatoire pour l'ensemble du personnel
en salle et en cuisine ainsi que pour
les clients lorsqu'ils se déplacent bien
entendu s'agissant des bars toujours
dans les zones vertes je vous rappelle
la règle il faut te éviter les risques à
l'intérieur des espaces dans les
endroits où on est rassemblée
potentiellement plus serré et où la
circulation de l'air le renouvellement
de l'air est moins bien garantie c'est
pour ça que nous demanderons aux
exploitants de ne pas autoriser la
consommation debout à l'intérieur dans
beaucoup de cas ces deux barrières des
tables où l'on peut boire un verre ou
manger ça ne posera pas de problème on
demandera de ne pas autoriser la
consommation debout à l'intérieur dans
les départements qui font l'objet d'une
vigilance particulière les départements
de l'île de france
mayotte et la guyane seuls les terrasses
des cafés et des bars et des restaurants
pourront ouvrir au 2 juin
j'ai parfaitement conscience que c'est
une restriction et que c'est une
restriction qui lourde de conséquences
s'agissant de ces établissements dans
les zones oranges mais il nous a semblé
à la lumière de ce qui se pratique dans
les autres pays à la lumière des risques
que nous avons identifié que c'était la
bonne mesure à prendre au moins pour les
trois semaines qui viennent
évidemment comme pour toutes les mesures
que je viens d'évoquer elles seront
réévaluées à la fin
du mois de juin ou plus exactement avant
le 22 juin qui est la date de notre
prochain rendez vous un mot sur les
hébergements touristiques les
hébergements touristiques les villages
vacances les campings pourront ouvrir à
partir du 2 juin dans tous les
départements à l'exception de ceux qui
font l'objet d'une vigilance
particulière dans ce département la les
hébergements en question les campings
les auberges collectif ne pourrons
rouvrir que dans la troisième phase de
déconfinement c'est à dire après le 22
juin dans tous les départements les
colonies de vacances pourront re ouvrir
à compter du 22 juin
et c'est évidemment une bonne nouvelle
s'agissant des déplacements depuis
plusieurs mois nous avons voulu éviter à
tout prix que des personnes en
provenance de zones dans lesquelles le
virus circule puis se déplacer dans des
zones dans lesquelles le virus circule
ré - est-ce que l'idée c'était
évidemment d'éviter la dissémination du
virus
c'est pour cette raison que nous avons
fermé nos frontières les frontières
extérieures à l'europe et les frontières
intérieures à l'europe c'est aussi pour
ces raisons que lors de la première
phase du déconfinement nous avons décidé
d'interdire les déplacements de plus de
cent kilomètres à l'intérieur du
territoire national
sauf motif impérieux
aujourd'hui le virus circule encore très
activement dans certaines parties du
monde
c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé
d'évaluer leur région du 15 juin avec
l'ensemble des pays européens
si nos frontières extérieures à l'europe
devait ou non réussir
pour quel ressortissant de quel pays et
avec quelles modalités de 14 n le cas
échéant donc pour tout ce qui est à
l'extérieur de l'espace européen
la décision sera prise collectivement
avec l'ensemble des pays européens à
l'horizon du 15 ou à l'intérieur de
l'europe
l'épidémie est en train de ralentir
c'est vrai en france mais c'est vrai
partout en europe
c'est pourquoi la france sera favorable
à une réouverture des frontières
intérieures de l'europe à compter du 15
juin si la situation sanitaire le permet
bien entendu 114 haine pour les
voyageurs en provenance de pays
européens
mais comme nous le faisons depuis le
début de la crise nous appliquerons des
mesures de réciprocité vis-à-vis des
états européens qui déciderait de fermer
leurs frontières ou d'imposer des 14 n
aux français à l'intérieur du pays en
france comme je l'expliquais même si
certains déplacement nécessite encore
une vigilance importante
la tension est globalement moindre qu'au
début du déconfinement la mesure
d'interdiction de déplacement de plus de
100 km a été très utile durant ces trois
dernières semaines pour limiter la
propagation du virus
elle a été bien respecté par les
français je les en remercie mais
aujourd'hui avec la pression qui a
baissé
cette mesure n'a plus de justification à
compter du 2 juin
il est donc mis fin à l'interdiction de
déplacement de plus de 100 kilomètres de
chez soi
je voudrais dire que la fin de cette
interdiction ne doit pas signifier un
relâchement dans la tension
il est bien vrai que - on circule moins
le virus se propage aussi j'en appelle à
la responsabilité de chacun vous pouvez
vous déplacer vous pouvez aller en
congés annuels
mais dans toute la mesure du possible si
vous pouvez différer un déplacement
lointain
c'est probablement plus raisonnable et
j'appelle chaque français dans le cadre
de ces nouvelles règles au même esprit
de responsabilité dont ils ont fait
preuve depuis le début de cette crise un
point sur un point important pour tous
nos concitoyens sur la culture les
loisirs et les vacances grâce aux
efforts faits par chacun pour respecter
les gestes barrière la distanciation
physique notre vie sociale notre vie
culturelle notre vie sportive va pouvoir
reprendre
plus largement je les dis dès ce
week-end les parcs et jardins seront
ouverts sur tout le territoire en zone
dite orange comme partout en france le
port du masque pourra être imposé dans
de nombreux espaces à la demande des
maires à la demande des maires les
préfets pourront par mesure de
précaution supplémentaire imposé le port
du masque dans les espaces publics
ce sera aux acteurs locaux d'en décider
à compter du 2 juin
seront aussi également réouvert sur tout
le territoire les plages les lacs les
plans d'eau les musées les monuments
sont également ouverts sur l'ensemble du
territoire le port du masque
il sera lui aussi obligatoire pour un
certain nombre d'activités
une distinction va cependant devoir
encore être réalisées dans les trois
prochaines semaines entre les zones
vertes et les zones oranges dans les
zones vertes les salles de spectacle et
les théâtres pourront ouvrir à compter
du 2 juin
je ne méconnais absolument pas la
difficulté pratique de réouvrir ses
équipements dès lors que la
programmation s'est trouvée perturbée
que les répétitions n'ont pas pu
intervenir mais il nous semble que si
certains peuvent le faire alors qu'ils
le fassent les règles de distanciation
physique devront y être respecté par une
organisation spécifique des places
assises une gestion des flux conformes
au protocole sanitaire de ces espaces et
le port du masque
il sera obligatoire dans les mêmes zones
vertes les activités sportives pourront
aussi ouvrir plus largement avec
l'ouverture du gymnase et des salles de
sport je sais que c'était une décision
attendue par beaucoup à la proche de
l'été les piscines
ils seront également ouvertes dès le 2
juin toujours dans les zones vertes les
parcs de loisirs seront ouverts pour les
activités permettant la distanciation
physique avec le respect de règles
strictes et notamment une jauge maximale
de 5000 personnes permettant là encore
d'éviter les trop grands brassages de
population pour les installations que je
viens de citer les salles de spectacles
des théâtres gymnases et salles de sport
les piscines les parcs de plein air
elles ne seront ouvertes dans les zones
orange qu'à compter du 22 juin
enfin partout sur le territoire les
cinémas rouvriront à compter du 22 juin
c'est une demande qui nous a été fait
par les exploitants de cinéma eux-mêmes
qui voulait que la réouverture soit
nationale de façon à pouvoir organiser
la programmation des salles et nous
faisons droit à cette demande
elle interviendra à compter du 22 juin
prochain je voudrais insister sur le
fait que notre